si tiene cáncer de pulmón de células
pequeñas a menudo se está edificando un
sistema más simple de dos partes porque
las opciones de tratamiento no varían
mucho entre los estadios más detallados
utilizados para describir el cáncer de
pulmón de células no pequeñas en el
cáncer de pulmón de células pequeñas en
estadio limitado las células
cancerígenas se encuentran en un pulmón
y pueden encontrarse en los tejidos
entre los pulmones y en ganglios
linfáticos cercanos si se descubre el
cáncer en el otro pulmón en los ganglios
linfáticos del otro lado del pecho o en
otras partes del cuerpo
se llama estadio generalizado